علمنا أن مولر أثار
احتمال أن الرئيس ترامب كذب
عليه عندما قال الرئيس إنه
لا يتذكر أي محادثات مع
روجر ستون حول ويكيليكس التي من
الواضح أنها حصلت على تلك الرسائل الإلكترونية من DNC
التي كان من المفترض أن الروس
قد اخترقوا ذلك  كانت تلحق الضرر
بهيلاري كلينتون في حملتها الانتخابية ،
علمنا أن شهادة
مايكل كوهين ترامب ، محامي ترامب ،
ورئيس الحملة السابق بول مانافورت ونائب
رئيس الحملة ريك غيتس ، تشير إلى أن
الرئيس ترامب تحدث مع روجر
ستون حول ويكيليكس وهذا
الإصدار المعلق لرسائل البريد الإلكتروني الضارة هذه.  أعلم
أنك على دراية بهذا ، هل تعتقد أن
الرئيس ترامب كذب على روبرت
مولر ومحققيه بشأن هذه القضية ،
نعم أعتقد أنه من الواضح جدًا أنه كذب
وأنه ارتكب جريمة
وأعتقد أن هذا هو الحال أيضًا كما أوضح
مولر في تقريره  أن السبب الوحيد
لعدم توجيه الاتهام إلى الرئيس هو
أن مولر كان يعمل تحت
إدارة جوس  المبادئ التوجيهية التي
تنص على أنه لا يمكن
توجيه لائحة اتهام ضد الرئيس الحالي إذا لم يكن حاضرًا ، أعتقد
أنه كان من الممكن أن يتم توجيه الاتهام إليه وكان يجب
أن يكون لعرقلة العدالة أو
لشيء له علاقة
بالتآمر مع روسيا جيدًا
للكذب على تامالا الكذب
إلى أن الكذب على
الالتزامات تجاه اللجنة الأم يعتبر جريمة